So our next speaker certainly does not
need any introduction.
He is the man you cornered by his seat.
He is the man you cornered in the foyer
and he is the man you cornered outside
the bathroom.
So please put your hands together for
Dr. Peterson.
So I was kind of perplexed about what I
was going to say today because I'm not a
media expert by any stretch of the
imagination.
But,
uh,
I was speaking with Jonathan Patio this
morning because he's staying in the
same,
same airbnb is my wife and I,
and he suggested that I talk to you
about my experiences with media over the
last year.
And I thought,
well that's a,
that's something I know about.
So it's always good when you're talking
to people to talk to some talk about
something that you know about.
That's actually a really good tip for
public speaking,
right?
Well,
it's really true.
You have to remember that you should
know about three times as much about the
topic as,
as you need to talk about the topic.
And then you have places you can go and
you know,
you can wander round a little bit and be
a little spontaneous.
So that's really useful.
And um,
but then I also thought that makes sense
because nobody knows anything about the
situation with regards to the media now.
And so we're all feeling our way.
And so because the technological
transformations are so rapid and you
know,
they're going to come one after the
other in the next 10 years,
I don't think we can even imagine what's
coming down the pipes and we're all
struggling to keep up.
And you know,
we don't even know how much of the
current state of more radical political
polarization is actually a secondary
consequence of technological
transformations that we don't
understand.
Because I was thinking today about,
you know,
about facebook and about twitter and
about youtube and about the idea that
people are in an echo chamber.
And I'm not really sure that's the right
metaphor.
I think we might be in an amplifier
rather than an echo chamber.
You know,
and I've thought for a long time that
when I'm,
when I'm thinking about the effect of
the individual,
I read something that Solzhenitsyn said
at one point,
and I think he was citing a,
an ancient Christian theologian who
defined the universe as a place that's
whose circumference was nowhere and
whose center was everywhere.
And I really liked that idea.
It's,
and I think it's actually relatively
true from a technical perspective,
like from a physical perspective,
but Solzhenitsyn pointed out that each
of us was to be regarded as a center of
the Cosmos and,
and that we have the power that's
associated with that.
And I've thought about that a lot
because there's something about it
that's,
it's either obviously true or it's true
enough so that we all acted out when we
interact with each other because we
treat each other like conscious beings
who have a destiny and hand who have
choices and who make choices that are
important and who make choices that can
be good or bad or even good and evil.
We all act like that.
So we,
we act that out.
And I was thinking that you can think of
network models in that way.
You know,
um,
you can think of human beings as like 9
billion dots in a row and there's no
connections between the dots.
And then you're sorta like a dust mote
in the wind and who the hell cares what
you think anyways and you don't have any
impact on things.
Or you can recognize that you're at the
center of a network system and that you
know,
you know a thousand people or you will
in your lifetime or perhaps more than a
thousand people and then they know a
thousand people.
So you're separated by one person from
1,000,002 people from a billion.
And that's a much better way to think.
And we are seriously networked together
and we're networked together more now
than we ever have beaten.
And so one of the things that that might
mean is that the choices you make are
amplified and distributed not only far
faster than they ever have been,
but with far more impact.
And you know,
one of the things that Carl Jung pointed
out was that when he had this idea that
when science split that that elk,
you know,
is the root of science in some sense,
it's this dream like sub straight out of
which science emerged.
And,
but alchemy was kind of a weird ad
mixture of religious thinking and
scientific thinking because those two
things hadn't been differentiated back
when there were alchemists.
And Ewan believed that what had happened
in,
in Europe,
at least first was that the scientific
and developing me blew up and expanded
at an exponential rate.
And that led to this advanced
technological civilization that we have.
But that the moral dimension that was
embedded in the religious symbolism
didn't develop at all.
And so we're in this unstable situation
where we're far more technologically
proficient than we are wise.
And that that's actually a big problem
because obviously the more powerful the
tools you generate,
the more intelligent ethically you
better be or things are going to really,
uh,
are,
are going to go to hell in a handbasket
very,
very rapidly.
You know,
and I had this thought,
I think I shared a little bit last night
that,
you know,
in the next five years,
six years,
we're going to develop pretty viciously
intelligent ai systems.
And that's already happening.
You know,
I mean,
they're monitoring youtube and they're
monitoring facebook and they're
monitoring google and they're trying to
make ethical decisions,
these ai systems.
And the problem is,
is that the ethical presuppositions of
the programmers are being embedded into
the infrastructure of the net.
And that's a hell of a thing to think
because it means that for better or
worse,
we're building automated intelligence is
that reflect our own morality.
And we better be very careful about what
our morality is if we're going to
automate it.
Because automated systems are incredibly
powerful.
So,
so that's,
that's kind of,
that's where we're at,
at least to some degree in terms of the
new technological transformations with
in communication technology.
You know,
it puts each of us at the,
at the center of a wide web of
connections and makes the consequences
of our moral decisions much more
immediately manifest to each of us.
And it kind of begs the question too,
like how should you behave on facebook
and how should you behave on twitter?
I think twitter drives me a little bit
crazy,
you know,
um,
I'm on at a fair bit and I'm not sure
it's a good thing.
And I tend to distribute things that are
alarming,
let's say in some sense maybe they are
ideological or ideologically they're
disturbing.
And I was thinking about that today in
preparation for this talk.
And I wasn't really sure that was
necessarily a good idea because there
are a lot of alarming things happening
all the time,
everywhere obviously.
Um,
and now we can share all of them always
all the time.
And so that means that instead of
hearing about one alarming thing a day,
you're hearing about like 500 alarming
things a day.
And so then,
you know,
what are you supposed to do about that?
Is that,
does that indicate the state that
there's a state of emergency?
Well,
you don't know cause you don't know how
to calibrate the information.
So I was thinking,
well maybe the right way to behave on
twitter is only two forward good things
that are happening.
You know,
cause there's lots of good things that
are happening.
But I actually don't know the answer to
that.
I,
I have no idea and I don't think anybody
else does either.
I do know that there are studies with
regards to facebook that show that the
more time that you spend on facebook,
the more depressed you are and that it
looks like it's a causal relationship
rather than just a correlational
relationship.
And it seems to have something to do
with the fact that facebook is one of
those platforms where everybody puts up
an advertisement for their life,
right?
It's like,
here I am with my new girlfriend in The
Bahamas being happy and here I am in a
mountain being happy.
And it's like,
it's not you like miserable with the
cover over your head,
unable to get out of bed.
You don't,
you don't,
you don't broadcast that.
You can think,
well,
I means you're presenting people with a
falsely positive view of your life.
And then they compare their lives to it
and they come up short and you think,
well that's a kind of deception.
But by the same token,
you don't stop random strangers on the
street and tell them how miserable your
life is.
Right?
They don't want to hear about that.
They,
they want to see a facade of normality
in,
you know,
just casual day to day interactions.
And so part of prosocial behavior is
only to put what's at least,
you know,
normative and good forward.
So it doesn't matter.
I mean,
so I don't think that's necessarily
deception,
but the mass consequence of that is
something that we don't understand at
all.
And so,
well,
so with that sort of introduction,
I'm going to kind of walk you through my
experience with social media and let's
say the old media,
for lack of a better word,
and I'll try to give you a balanced
account and to tell you,
well,
it's to see if I can draw some
conclusions about what's happened to me,
my life.
For the last year has been so busy that
I haven't had proper time to reflect on
what's been happening.
And even if I did,
I wouldn't,
I'm not exactly sure I would be able to
understand it anyways because it isn't
sure.
I'm not,
I don't think I have a framework of
reference within which to put it.
So I started working for this company
called Television TV Ontario About 15,
16 years ago.
I had talked to a producer,
his name was Waldeck Shimberg.
He's a emigrate Polish Jew in a really
smart guy.
And uh,
he phoned me up at the university and
one of the things that distinguishes me
to some degree from my colleagues is
that I'll talk to the press and that I'm
actually not afraid of them or
distrustful of them.
Like a lot of my colleagues,
not all of them are like,
they're critical of the press,
partly in an arrogant way and partly in
a defensive way.
They say,
well,
they always get it wrong.
It's like,
well,
first of all,
there isn't a day and they don't always
get it wrong.
And you know,
they,
they'll also shy away from the press as
if they're being intruded upon when the
truth is generally speaking.
The idea is that they're putting forward
aren't of sufficient interest to draw
public attention anyways.
And so,
but I talked to what EC for a long time
and he invited me to go on a couple of,
of shows and then uh,
um,
then I ended up on TV shows the agenda,
which is a pretty good public affairs
show.
It's one of the few,
I would say deep new shows left that,
that,
that are on normal broadcast tv and you
know,
they go into issues in some depth,
although they fragmented that up a bit
in recent years.
And I became a fairly common guest on
those shows and people seem to like what
I was saying,
which always surprised me.
I mean,
but,
but it was good because you know,
it must be pretty damn horrible to put
yourself out in the public eye and face
primary criticism for what you're doing.
I think that would be unbearable in some
sense unless you were very,
very strongly constituted.
And then,
well,
that went on for a while and we'll deck
was running this a series called big
ideas,
which was actually quite prescient,
you know,
so he had lecturers come to Toronto and,
and he had all pretty much all the major
public intellectuals in the world over a
period of about five years or six years
or so,
come and deliver bare bones lectures of
this sort fundamentally need taped them
and put them on tv,
you know,
and,
and uh,
that was sort of unheard of.
The production quality was well high,
but not overproduced weren't multiple
cameras and edits and,
and intelligent commentary from people
in the background.
It was purely content driven,
you know,
and it actually got pretty popular on,
on itunes and you can still find the
lectures there,
but Tvo couldn't they,
they,
they pulled the show even though their
primary,
a mandate from the government was to
educate the public.
And this was a very low budget show with
very high quality minds that people were
actually watching and downloading a lot
on itunes,
but they didn't seem to take the
nonstandard media with any degree of
seriousness.
And you know,
that's kind of a common human attribute,
which is that if you don't know about
something,
you don't take it seriously.
Right.
And it's because if you don't know about
it,
well it's just gray and fuzzy,
right to you.
You have no differentiated knowledge.
So it's easy to oversimplify it.
And I think part of the problem with the
classical media,
let's say,
trying to make a transition to the
digital age is that they have no idea
what the digital media is.
Like.
I was watching an MSNBC,
a clip the other day about this robot.
I think her name is Sophia,
who,
who has a fairly advanced degree of
artificial intelligence and who can
manifest pretty realistic human facial
emotions.
And uh,
it was a four minute clip and had a 32nd
ad at the beginning of it and you
couldn't skip the ad.
And I thought there's a real arrogance
on the part of the MBA,
ms NBC people to put that on Youtube.
Because anybody who's familiar with the
youtube,
let's say,
culture knows that what you get to put a
ten second ad on and then you get to
skip it after five seconds if you want.
Like you can't ask people to pay 30
seconds of attention for four minutes of
content.
It violates the norms.
And so it,
it only had about 12,000 views.
And that's a really interesting example
of Marshall Mcluhan's idea that the
medium is the message,
right?
As you build a new technological
infrastructure.
And it's sort of like the old thing
because youtube is sort of like a TV
network,
but it's also not like a TV network at
all,
partly for example,
because when you put something on
Youtube,
it's permanent.
And that's way different than broadcast
TV.
Like it's raw,
it's seriously revolutionarily
different.
And so,
and it's also the case to that then this
is a strange thing and I don't think the
classic media understands this either,
is that youtube people don't like high
production values.
In fact,
they're very cynical about them.
And I think that's because they've come
to identify advanced editing and Glitz
as markers that the information is
actually being manipulated,
which of course it is now for better or
worse.
I mean editing doesn't have to be
manipulating,
but it certainly can be.
And so,
and besides that,
a lot of the more tech savvy people that
watch youtube can duplicate those sort
of special effects in their own home in
half an hour.
So they're not there.
They're no longer markers of the kind of
competence and technological prowess
that would signal the sort of competence
that you could trust.
So,
so what youtube viewers seem to like is
basically ordinary people more or less
trying to have an intelligent
conversation about something confusing
and important and the,
the attention span that people are
willing to devote to that is actually
quite remarkable for for a medium that
was nothing but cute cat videos say five
years ago.
The fact that like a lot of my lectures
and like Joe Rogan's podcast like three
hours long,
it's like what the hell?
People weren't supposed to have that
capacity to pay attention in this era of
fragmented attention,
you know,
in Rogan,
I don't know if you know this or not.
Um,
he has 120 million downloads a month
now.
So that's 1.5 billion downloads a year.
And so the last time I saw him,
and that was with Brett who just spoke,
um,
I,
I asked him what it was like to be the
most powerful interview or the world has
ever seen because I think he probably
is,
if you think about it and sheer numbers,
I mean maybe Walter cronkite back in the
60s had some comparable influence,
but he said,
I just don't think about it.
And like,
what,
what the hell is he supposed to think
about it?
Because no one knows what to think about
that.
And so he just has the conversations and
posts some and away he goes,
but he has no idea what role he's
currently playing in society and we
don't have proper metrics for measuring
it and we don't understand it at all.
So anyways,
I did these big idea lectures with,
with air con and they were ranked on,
on uh,
the Dvo channel and the five lectures or
six lectures I did all ended up in the
top 20,
which really surprised me.
But it was an indication that there was
something about what I was talking about
that for which there was a market and
now there's,
there's some reasons for that.
I think,
you know what,
when I,
I wrote a book from 1984 to 1999 called
maps of meaning.
And a lot of the things I talk about
come out of all the reading I did during
that period because I was reading an
insane amount and thinking really
nonstop 16 hours a day.
Like the only way I could stop myself
from thinking was to go work out with
weights.
I couldn't shut off my,
my concern with the issues that I was
dealing with and I was spending about
three hours a day writing and I did that
everyday for 15 years and that was the
consequences.
That was the book.
And
the writing also helped a tremendous
amount because it helps clarify your
thinking,
writing,
you know,
because actually you're smarter when
you,
right?
Because you can externalize your
thoughts and then you can,
you can use your working memory to
analyze what you've written instead of
remembering the thought.
And so you're,
you're externalizing your memory.
You can analyze what you thought,
you can refine it,
you can reorder it.
You can edit like mad with a word
processor,
which is also a very new thing to it.
Editing is very difficult if you have to
do that with pen and paper with a
typewriter,
it's like,
forget it.
You get your first draft and that's it.
And so,
but what I was doing with maps of
meaning was I was trying to solve a
problem.
And the problem was it was the problem
as far as I was concerned that underlie
the conflict between the Western world
and the communist world essentially.
And that problem was,
well the reason it was a problem was
because we were so highly armed,
even as we are now.
And of course that problem is
manifesting itself once again with North
Korea that might render everything we're
talking about completely irrelevant,
right?
We cause we don't know which catastrophe
is the one most worth worrying about,
but I was interested in the conflict
between the communist way of looking at
the world and the Western way of looking
at the world.
And I think I actually had a postmodern
concern with that because one of the
things I was curious about was,
well the world is susceptible to a
multitude of interpretations and
opinions and the Communist
interpretation is one form of
interpretation and the western
capitalist democratic form of
interpretation is another form of
interpretation.
And is there any grounds on which you
can determine that one of those is
superior to the other or more correct
than the other?
Or is it a matter purely of opinion and
social organization or maybe even
warfare to determine who's going to be
the victor?
Maybe there's no other way of
determining who's going to be the victor
then actual conflict.
It's certainly possible.
And so I started to look underneath
belief structures and I didn't know you
could do that really to begin with.
You know,
my first degree was in political science
and I kind of wandered out of that when
the professors kept insisting to me in
the upper years of my studies that all
of the conflict between human beings was
driven by economic disparity.
And I just never bought that because
that's like saying that people fight
about what they value.
And for me that just begged the question
of,
well yeah,
a fair enough.
Obviously it's,
it's,
it's almost self evident.
But the real question is why do they
value what they value?
Because human beings are quite a diverse
lot and it's not self evident why we
value some things rather than other
things.
Like if you're starving to death,
it's obvious that you're going to value
food.
But that's a limit case.
You know,
it's,
it's not that interesting.
So it's,
it's,
it's too simplified.
So I didn't find that a compelling
explanation and I still don't,
I think the economic explanation for,
for human conflict is,
is shallow and tautological even.
And then I started to read some people
whose,
whose writings really gripped me.
And I think that's an interesting
phenomenon.
You know,
and I was studying psychology by this
point.
I switched into psychology and,
um,
I was starting to read the
psychoanalysts and I really got,
I really got interested in what they had
to say,
um,
partly from reading Freud because I was
really interested in his analysis of
family dynamics and have dreams,
but more particularly from reading
young.
And one of the things I learned from
young,
which really has never ceased to shock
me,
was his,
see,
he basically made a point.
And the point was that you're not master
in your own house.
That there are forces that are,
are operating on you at an unconscious
level that determine,
for example,
the direction of your attention.
So for example,
you know how sometimes you'll read
something to really grip you and then
you'll read something else and you like,
you can't even concentrate on it.
And you might say,
well,
I need to concentrate on this boring
thing,
you know,
cause an exam depends on it or a
promotion.
And there's just no damn way you're
reading it and your attention flips all
over the place and,
and you know you're undisciplined and
all that.
But,
but then you have this other thing and
it just grips you like this and you
think,
okay,
well what,
what's doing that?
It's not your will.
Because your would be the thing that
would allow you to concentrate on
whatever you chose to concentrate on.
It's something underneath your will
that's actually directing your
attention.
And you could say,
well it's random,
but of course it's not.
It's maybe random if you have a serious
case of schizophrenia.
But,
and I think in some sense that's
actually the definition of
schizophrenia.
But it's not random.
If you're a functioning human being,
the thing that grips your attention and
directs it to one place or another is
something that's what's a deep instinct.
It's a manifestation of what union
called the self,
which is a very interesting idea.
So human thought,
this is such a cool idea.
He thought that the mechanism that
directed your attention in the present
was your future self attempting to
manifest itself in the present world.
So you might say,
well you have a potential and that
potential is what you could be in time.
And in order for that potential to
manifest itself,
it has to be palpable in the present.
And the way that instinct for further
develop manifests itself in the present
is by directing your attention towards
things that are likely to increase your
competence and further your growth right
now.
And that's just an unbelievable idea.
You know,
it's like your,
your potential better self beckoning to
you in the present.
Amazing.
And I really can't think of a better
explanation for it than that.
That's a,
that's a really good explanation but a
very frightening one because it means in
some sense that you're,
that something as fundamental as your
attention is more or less controlled by
processes that are so deep that you
don't have a tremendous amount of
voluntary control over them.
Like you can interact with the forces to
some degree,
but you know,
you're not one of those per creatures
that can just tell yourself what to do.
Life would be really easy if that's what
it was like right here.
It's time to go to the gym three days a
week,
two hours a day.
It's like,
you know,
you're superman in two years and you can
eat properly and you know,
you're,
you're not going to drink too much and
you're not going to take cocaine and all
of these things.
You just tell yourself that and bang,
you quit.
And it's kind of weird that it isn't
that way,
but it's really seriously not that way.
Anyways,
when I was looking at the difference
between the Communist system in the
western capitalist system,
I started to get underneath the belief
systems to find out what was there at
Ewan was extremely,
how helpful and other thinkers that,
I'm sure you've heard me mentioned,
if you've listened to my lectures,
need Shin and dusty,
Husky and social knits and seem to be
the people who had dug deepest down into
those subterranean levels.
And what I found,
I think was that the communist system
was very,
was very shallow.
It was predicated on a set of rational
assumptions that were generated by a
handful of people with no real
biological here or historical rooting.
Um,
and I think that the fact that that was
the case was part of the reason why when
those ideas unfolded in real time,
they were so murderous.
They just weren't imagine that,
you know,
Karl Marx was thinking,
well,
here's the game that we're playing in.
Here are the rules.
And so that he laid out the rules
explicitly and then people made
societies that follow those rules.
And it turned out that that game didn't
work at all.
He just got it wrong.
And like seriously Ra.
Whereas in the west,
the ideas emerged from a,
an unbroken historical process that
stretches back probably to the beginning
of civilization,
say maybe,
maybe all the way back to Africa,
who knows how,
how,
how ancient these ideas are.
And there's,
there's an unbroken con continuity of
ideas that emerged up and that,
and they're expressed in symbolic form
and it's on that symbolic platform,
which actually matches our biology and
our behavior that are more articulated
ideas rest upon.
And so I found that extremely useful and
surprising.
I mean,
it wasn't what I expected.
And,
and at the same time I was,
I was,
I had another problem that emerged while
I was dealing with this and one was that
I come to understand what group identity
meant to people.
Like you have to have a group identity
because you live with other people and
LE,
unless you have a shared identity.
Jonathan talked about this a bit.
Unless you have a central pole around
which you're all oriented,
it's all chaotic and confused and you're
in constant conflict and warfare.
It's like that's a bad thing you do.
You do not want that.
And you're all confused individually and
all of that.
That's a state of chaos.
It's unbearable.
But if you tighten up the group identity
too great a degree,
say like the Nazis tried to do,
then the probability that you'll come to
blows with other groups reaches a almost
a point of certainty.
Right?
And so it seemed to me that human beings
were damned if they did and damned if
they didn't.
On the,
on the one hand,
if you dropped your group identity,
then you fragmented and degenerated into
the chaos.
And if you gripped hard to your group
identity,
then you,
you tilted towards totalitarianism and
group conflict.
And then I thought,
well,
that was okay in the past to tilt
towards group conflict because,
you know,
when we had sticks and swords,
we,
we'd have a war in.
Lots of people would get killed in,
lots of people would get hurt,
but the entire planet wouldn't burst
into flames.
Right?
So,
you know,
this,
this inborn
dichotomy of,
of catastrophe that characterized human
existence wasn't something that could
spiral into complete destruction.
And so we could get away with it.
But now in a thermonuclear age,
it's like we can't get away with it,
but that's still what we're like.
We're still like that.
And so for months I thought,
oh my God,
you know,
I always believed that if you could get
to the bottom of a problem,
you could solve it.
Cause that,
that was sort of the definition of
getting to the bottom of it.
You know,
you,
uh,
solution would emerge.
And when I got to the bottom of it,
as far as I could go,
I thought,
oh,
it's group identity.
And like group fostered warfare and
catastrophe on the one hand and
degenerate nihilism on the other.
It's like well jigs up.
There's no way out of that.
And I had a prophetic dream at that
point,
which,
and I won't tell you the details of
that,
but it outlined a third pass to me that,
that I had already picked up to some
degree from reading young and also Eric
[inaudible] who is one of young great
students.
And that was,
that had to do with the embodiment of
the idea of the hero and the individual
as the like the pathway of the
courageous individual as the mediating
force between the chaos of nihilism and
totalitarianism,
totalitarianism of authority,
authority,
authoritarian certainty that there was a
third path.
And then I started to understand its
relationship to religious thinking
mostly to Christianity,
but partly because that's my tradition,
you know,
in so far as I'm a western person say,
and I understood as well that it had
something to do and that this was what
it was dramatized in the,
in the,
uh,
in the passion story in the New
Testament was that it had something to
do with taking responsibility for
malevolence because Christ is
architecturally the person who takes the
world's sins upon himself.
And what that means in some sense is
that if you read about history,
read about Nazi Germany,
you read about the Soviet Gulags,
you don't read as an observer looking at
what other people have done.
You read as the subject and the object
of the history.
You're both the person who was
persecuted and the victimizer at the
same time.
And you,
you have to see both of those inside us
actual forces in order to understand
history properly.
And of course,
that's a very,
very terrifying thing to do.
It's easier to take the part of victim
in some sense,
even though that's terrible,
right?
Because who wants to be the victim of a
concentration camp,
obviously,
but maybe that's preferable ethically to
being the perpetrator.
But when you're reading about Auschwitz,
you're not reading about past history of
reading about exactly what people are
like.
And that's a very terrifying thing.
And so one of the things you have to do
if you're going to take responsibility
for the nature of your being is to take
responsibility for the malevolence.
That's truly part of human nature.
And that's,
that's part of the encounter with the
shadow from the union perspective.
And you know,
one of ewing's proposition was that the
human shadow reaches all the way down to
hell.
And you know,
we're used to thinking of religious
language maybe even as outdated
superstition.
But if you take that sort of statement
seriously from a psychological
perspective,
what it means in some sense is that the
malevolence that resides inside you,
at least in potential,
is of the same sort as the malevolence
that produces the worst things that
human beings have ever done.
And so,
and I couldn't see any way out of that
argument.
I mean,
the more I read about the gulag system
in the USSR and what happened in China,
what happened in Nazi Germany,
the more it became evident to me that
these weren't topped down systems
imposed by tyrants on an unwilling
innocent population,
but decisions on the part of entire
cultures to go down a certain road.
Often the leaders were following,
which I would say it was particularly
the case with Hitler,
which isn't to deny him his criminal
culpability,
but Hitler was unbelievably good at
letting the crowd tell him what to say.
You know,
he was a,
he was a mirror for the crowd and he was
a good orator,
but he paid attention to the crowd.
And so when he said something that made
everyone cheer,
you know,
they're dark hearts would come out in
the mob and cheer about something he
said that was say dramatic or,
or vengeful.
Well then he'd say more of that and the
things that he said that were peaceful,
that produced no emotional reaction from
the crowd.
He just said less of.
And so the crowd taught him over time
exactly what to sell them.
And that that can be good in some sense.
If a leader does that carefully,
that that means he's integrating what
the crowd wants with his style of
leadership.
But it can be terrible if the mob is the
crowd and the mob is outraged and out
for blood.
And that's what happened in Nazi
Germany.
And so you can't blame it on Hitler.
That's just not reasonable.
It's distributed through the entire
population and the individual level of
analysis that's most significant and a
well.
So there's malevolence that has to be
contended with.
And then the other element is that you
have to contend with the tragedy of
life.
And that's so in the,
in the passion of the Christ did that
and that story.
Christ of course encounters Satan in the
desert.
And so that's,
and he's tempted there.
And so that's the encounter with evil
archetypically speaking.
And then the crucifixion itself is the
encounter with the tragedy of life,
right?
It's betrayal and death voluntarily
accepted.
And so I understood that that was a
symbolic representation of the logos and
that that was the they,
what would you say?
The embodied manifestation of this
heroic path that mediated between these
two extremes.
And I was really useful.
Like that was a really useful discovery
for me.
And because there was implications to it
too,
and,
and profound implications that also seem
to work out in relationship to what I
was learning about clinical psychology.
So for example,
one of the things you do if you're a
clinical psychologist,
as you help people learn to encounter
things that they're afraid of in a
controlled manner and they get less,
they don't get less afraid,
they get braver.
So you actually act out the process of
confrontation with tragedy,
voluntary conference question with
tragedy.
And that's curative.
It doesn't matter if you're exposing
them to their past or the present or
things they're worried about in the
future.
As long as they decide to do it
voluntarily,
they get stronger and better.
So you think,
well,
what's the limit to that?
Well,
the limit is to accept the limitations
and catastrophes of your own mortality
voluntarily.
And that's the potentially the proper
pathway through life,
or at least it's the least bad pathway
through life,
which is something,
you know,
and then I think the same can be said
fairly decisively for the willingness to
grapple with,
with malevolence,
uh,
on a personal and individual level,
you know?
So anyways,
I started to lecture about that and,
and,
and to lay out those ideas more and more
clearly over the years as I've been
lecturing.
And that's what I did for TV Ontario.
And I think that that's why the lectures
became popular because,
you know,
I'd put some words to ideas that people
already knew and could revitalize a
symbolic vocabulary that people had
become divorced from and,
and that there was a hole in the culture
exactly where those ideas needed to be.
And so people found that they were,
well,
people tell me when they come and talk
to me,
they said,
well,
when you're talking,
it's like,
I already know what you're saying,
but I don't have the words for it.
It's like,
well,
that's exactly what archetipal story is.
Like is that you all know the story.
You just don't know,
you know it or you know at a level that
you can't articulate,
but you still recognize it when you see
it and you still act it out and you see
it in other people.
But it's really,
really,
really good to have the words.
And that's partly why you should be very
careful about what you say and
particularly careful about what you
right now anyhow,
after the big ideas thing won't act,
came into my classes and tape maps of
meaning and made 1330 minutes or TV
shows out of them.
And that was pretty interesting.
And they were broadcast and kind of
evanescent because at that point they
weren't put on the web.
So they're broadcast,
they pretty much disappear.
Right.
And um,
so,
so fine.
So,
and I got some degree of,
what would you say I got?
I was exposed,
my ideas were exposed to a large number
of people,
tens of thousands of people as a
consequence of that.
And that seemed to go pretty well.
And so then youtube came along and I
thought,
well,
I don't know what this is,
this youtube thing,
you know,
the comments section makes you like,
what would you say wary about being
human?
I would say generally speaking,
and you know there was a lot of,
well there were a lot of things that it
would be easy to be contemptuous of on
Youtube,
like the canonical cute cat videos.
But I'm actually not so contempt chew us
of that or the interesting animal videos
because I think they actually speak to a
part of people that's actually quite
good.
We liked cats,
we like dogs,
we think animals are kind of cool.
And you know,
we take a break and look at,
look at something that's pleasant and
cute and maybe that's not so bad.
It's not serious,
but it's certainly not malevolent.
And that's something.
So I thought,
okay,
well I'll find these old videos I did
for Tvo and I'll put them up on youtube
and maybe I'll just take my classes.
And so I set up a,
because I have this theory that if it's
worth doing,
it's worth doing badly,
which you know,
it's true,
but it's also true that if it's worth
doing,
it's worth doing well and you just need
to know when to apply those two
principles.
And if you're loath to do something and
procrastinating,
then sometimes it's better to do it
badly.
And I thought,
well I can't get a whole production
studio up and running cause I just don't
have the time.
I'll get an IPAD and learn to use it and
get an level ear mic and just set the
thing up or maybe have a student film
it.
And so I did that for a couple of years
for my personality class in this maps of
meaning class,
which is the class where I outlined the
sorts of ideas that I just described to
you.
And uh,
last April I noticed that I'd had a
million views and about 15,000
subscribers,
you know,
and I thought,
huh,
million views,
hey,
that's an actually a lot of views.
It's like if I,
I've never write a scientific paper
that's been read a million times,
no one has,
that just never happens,
right?
That's happened zero times.
If it,
if you have a paper that's cited,
you know,
someone else refers to it and one of
their scientific papers a hundred times,
it's like that's a home run and a
thousand times is a miracle.
So,
and then if you write a book,
you know there's,
I think 1.2 million books published last
year,
something like that.
And I think 500 of them sold more than a
hundred thousand copies.
So that's a sea of books,
right?
It's,
it's an ocean of books and all of them
fail it really.
So,
so many of them fail that you might as
well never write a book because the
probability that it will fail is like
99.99% and that would be very depressing
if it wasn't the case that that's the
case for anything creative you ever do.
So it's just baseline probability.
But I thought,
well,
if I wrote a book and it sold a million
copies,
man,
I'd be out dancing in the street.
Uh,
probably not.
But you know,
you get the idea.
So what does it mean to have a million
youtube views?
Well,
who the hell knows?
Right?
I mean,
we don't have metrics for that.
We don't know what sort of influence
that's having.
We don't know anything about that.
We don't know whether we should take it
seriously or,
or if it's or who you're talking to or
anything.
But I thought,
well still it's a million.
And that's a lot.
And I thought,
well maybe this is,
this is more serious thing than I
initially envisioned.
And then I really thought about it and I
thought,
okay,
oh,
I get it.
Here's a hypothesis.
You know,
back in the medieval times and before,
if,
if you wanted to book someone had to
copy it by hand.
And so there weren't many books and they
were very expensive.
And so,
and then Gutenberg came along and
invented the movable type press and it
was like,
poof.
Books were inexpensive and everybody
could have them.
And not like was that was a major
revolution,
right?
It within 400 years,
almost everyone in the western world and
then very rapidly,
almost everyone in the entire world was
literate.
He could read silently even,
which was something that before that was
reserved for a very small number of
people because most people read out loud
when they read it all.
So that was a massive revolution.
And then I thought,
wait a minute,
maybe youtube is a Gutenberg revolution
because it allows the spoken word to
have the same reach and longevity as a
book.
Okay.
For the first time in human history,
spontaneous speeches can reach an
infinite audience for eye,
for an unspecified duration of time.
Well that's a whole new thing.
That's a,
that's an entirely new thing.
And maybe it's easier for people to
listen than it is for them to read.
You know?
I mean,
I'd rather read than listen cause I can
read way faster than I can listen.
But people will listen to a youtube
video at twice the normal speed,
sometimes more.
So you can circumvent that.
And then also with a youtube video,
if you convert it into a podcast,
let's say,
which I'll get to to a moment,
you all of a sudden have way more time
than you used to have because you can
listen to a podcast while you're doing
other things.
So you can do mundane,
the mundane things that you have to do
from day to day,
like commute and so on.
But you can listen to a podcast.
And I've found that my students,
my young students are now listening to
podcasts instead of music.
And that's really something,
you know,
because music of course,
it's been an unbelievably dynamic
cultural force for maybe the,
the primary artistic cultural force for
what maybe maybe since the 1950s
anyways.
And that's being supplanted to some
degree by podcasts.
And that's really something.
And then it also turns out that people
have an appetite for long,
detailed podcasts that are deep and
informative,
was like,
who the hell would've guessed that?
Like no one,
it's it.
It just sort of came out of nowhere.
And so I thought,
well,
maybe this is worth taking seriously.
And then like at the same time I was
interested in,
I've always been interested in
entrepreneur types and creative types.
They're,
they're high in this big five
personality trait called openness.
And there the people from whom all
innovation flows,
but it's very hard for creative people
to monetize their create creation
because to monetize something you have
to have the idea and then you have to
translate it into a product and then you
have to bring it to market and then you
have to sell it.
And then you have to develop customer
relationships and customer support.
And it's like,
by the time you do all that,
if you're going creative person,
you're either,
you've either been bought out and
shunted to the side or you're dead,
so you don't get to have the money.
You,
you produce the value,
but you can't monetize it.
And it's a big problem.
Uh,
it's why it's so frustrating to be a
creative person often,
you know?
Um,
so I was looking around for ways that
creative people could monetize their
production online,
mostly because I'm like far too curious
for my own good.
And,
uh,
my wife went off to visit her,
her,
uh,
her father for about a week can I had a
bunch of time,
uh,
I could stay up until three in the
morning,
which I shouldn't do and work.
And I found a site called Patriot and
Patriot allowed,
you know how patrion works.
It allows people to make voluntary
donations to support creative people who
are basically usually
making their work available for free,
which is,
I thought,
well that's pretty interesting.
It's appealing to the basic human desire
for reciprocity.
Like people actually don't like getting
something for nothing.
It kind of puts them in existential
debt.
And so they,
people generally feel that if they've
received something of value that they
would like to give something of value
back.
Now,
not everyone,
but most people,
most people.
And I thought,
well,
what the hell?
I'll set up the Patriot account and see
what happens.
So it took me about like six hours or
something like that to figure out how to
do it.
Exactly.
And how to make a little what a banner
on the youtube videos that was linked to
the Patriot account.
There was all sorts of little weird
tricks that you had to learn behind the
scenes.
And I thought,
well,
whatever,
we'll see what happens.
And then at the end of that month,
I had about 50,
60 subscribers and about $500 us a
month.
And I thought,
Huh,
that's pretty interesting.
You know,
I don't know what to make of it,
but I could take that money and increase
the production quality.
Um,
if that keeps happening and,
and I'll just run this and keep seeing
how it works.
So,
okay.
So that was pretty interesting.
And so I had thought through what it
meant,
what youtube meant,
that it was a Gutenberg revolution and
that deserve to be taken seriously.
And then I found this platform for
monetization for creative people.
Then the two things were married and
that was April last year.
And then at the same time I was writing
a book,
which is called 12 rules for life.
And some of you may have a,
or there's some flyers that are going to
be distributed that tell you about the
book.
But in any case,
I was reading this chapter in the book
called don't bother children when
they're skateboarding.
And it took me deep into the
polarization of society because I wasn't
very happy about the fact that children
are overprotected and that adventurous
children like skateboarders for example,
are often shut down when they're
manifesting their bravery and their
stupidity often.
But that's not always distinguishable
from bravery.
Right?
Cause you you,
that's like the trickster figure that
Jonathan was talking about earlier.
You know,
and he,
it's not always that easy to segregate
the people who take unrealistic or
unreasonable risks from those who are
courageously extending their competence
into the unknown.
And so anyways,
for reasons I won't tell you about that
took me deep into the,
into the political polarization
landscape with,
with,
uh,
you know,
with the increasing tension between the
left,
which I think is becoming increasingly
totalitarian and the right.
And,
um,
and also with what seems to be something
like an assault on,
well,
Jonathan called it the logos,
which I think is exactly right,
which I think is a reflection of niches,
death of God,
and an assault on masculinity,
which is often now seen as toxic or part
of the oppressive patriarchy,
really part patriarchy,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And so this was kind of making my blood
boil while I was,
while I was writing this,
you know,
because you get tangled up in that and
it,
it's kind of emotionally distressing.
And I saw the spread of these sorts of
radical leftist ideas through campus and
I thought we'd killed all that off back
in the 1990s.
You know,
there was a spike of political
correctness and about 92.
And I was in Boston at that point and it
kind of got pushed back and it
disappeared.
And I thought,
well,
that's good,
that's gone.
And then the economy boomed like mad in
the u s and people had other things to
concern themselves with.
And then all of a sudden,
you know,
three years ago or so,
it was like,
wow,
this is back with a vengeance.
It's like we ain't seen nothing yet.
And so that was bothering me.
And then in my clinical practice I had a
couple of clients who had been bullied
into poor states of mental health by
social justice warrior types at three
different workplaces.
And they were quite different people.
You know,
some of the more left leaning,
some of the more right leaning,
but all had the same stories.
They were sensible people and now they
were required to do things at their
workplace that they just couldn't
tolerate doing.
You know,
like sensitivity training or unconscious
bias training.
Or here's one story.
God,
this woman is this woman that I was
working with.
This is the stupidest story.
I wouldn't even believe it except she
showed me all the emails she worked at
this large bureaucracy.
We'll leave it at that.
And the,
the people at the bureaucracy would make
presentations with those,
you know,
those boards that you can set up that
have big pads of paper on them?
Well,
those pads of paper that you can flip
are called flip charts.
Okay.
And so,
but somebody got it into their head and
this was the manager of this,
of this particular client.
That flip was a racist term because
apparently you can call Filipinos flip.
I didn't know that.
And,
and so flip chart is actually insulting
to Filipinos.
And so,
and so then she showed me this string of
like 30 emails that had gone back and
forth within her company from the
management and a bunch of people,
you know,
that jen,
the typical suspects who are all
concerned about this.
And they ended up banning the word flip
chart.
And you know,
she was coming to talk to me saying,
look,
this is actually driving me crazy.
I can't believe this is that people are
spending their time doing this and that
we're required to assent to it as if it
isn't insane,
which of course it is.
And so,
um,
then then
I got wind of bill see 16 and I'd been
looking into the Ontario human rights
commission already at that point.
And I wasn't very happy with the Ontario
Human Rights Commission.
I think there it's fascist organization
masquerading under the guise of
compassion,
which is very,
very typical in and and very
intelligent.
Like if you're going to be a power
hungry or authoritarian,
who wants sensorial control,
the best way to allow yourself to be
able to look at yourself in the mirror
without screaming is to wear a mask of
compassion,
which is exactly what I think's
happening.
And Bill [inaudible] came out and it
purported to add transgender rights to
the list of protected rights in the
Canadian human rights code and in the
criminal code.
And like it was one of those Trojan
horses that Bret Weinstein just talked
about.
You read the legislation,
it's only two paragraphs long.
You Think,
Oh yeah,
Canadians are being nice to people who
you know are in a strange category and
get oppressed.
That's,
that's the surface of it.
But then I went back and I read all the,
because they said on the federal website
that it would be interpreted in
accordance with the policies developed
by the Ontario Human Rights Commission.
So I went read those policies and I
thought,
man,
first of all,
they were completely incoherent.
They were extraordinarily poorly
written.
They were philosophically appalling and
they couldn't have been designed to get
more people in trouble if that would
have been the purpose of the design.
So for example,
if you're a business owner,
they're not,
they're not pro capitalists,
let's put it that way.
If you're a business owner,
you are as responsible for the
utterances of their,
of your employees as if you were
uttering them yourself.
If the employee's utterance caused
offense,
whether or not they meant the offense
and whether or not there was any offense
taken on the part of the person that was
being offended.
It was like,
my God.
Really?
That's really the,
that's really the rule.
And that was like one of,
and there was another rule in there,
which was that the Ontario human rights
commission could suspend
jurisprudential,
um,
tradition in pursuit of their goals.
It was like clause 13 eight.
We know,
just 13,
eight.
It's just a little clause.
We can ignore all legal precedent.
So I was reading this and I thought,
what the hell,
this is absolutely insane.
And then at the same time,
the university hr department and Equity
Reit equity,
that's,
you hear that word,
you're someone utters that word and you
know they're ideologically possessed.
So you move away from them,
right?
You move away from them because equity
is a terrible,
it's a terrible word.
It's one of those words that masquerades
as compassionate is a dreadful,
terrible word.
So anyways,
the HR and equity department had decided
that,
you know,
the university was rife with systemic
racism and that was all implicit in our
unconscious biases and that all the h
and l,
all the staff,
hr staff would have to undergo mandatory
unconscious bias retraining.
Well then I thought,
okay,
okay.
Right.
Come on.
Really,
first of all,
you're using the implicit association
test,
right?
And actually I could tell you a little
bit about that test,
but only tell you a little bit
to use a test to diagnose it individual,
the test has to pass certain standards
of reliability,
which means it measures the same thing
within the same individual.
The same way across time because it's
like otherwise you have a ruler that's
made out of rubber.
It's not helpful,
right?
It has to produce the same results with
repeated administrations and it has to
predict behavior in a way that's
consistent and with some degree of
power.
Okay,
well the IAT is not reliable,
not nearly reliable enough to be used as
a diagnostic instrument,
and it's not particularly valid.
It predicts a little bit of behavior,
but not much like a fragment of behavior
may be enough to even have a significant
effect from,
from time to time,
but it's a small fraction like so your
unconscious biases,
which are actually indistinguishable
from your perceptions or maybe even your
ingroup favoritism and people are
characterized by in group favoritism,
which is why we like our families and
it's not easily distinguishable from
your,
from your reaction to novelty as well,
because you're,
your implicit racial prejudice under
some conditions is indistinguishable
from your preference for familiarity
over novelty.
So like the psych,
the psychological community is by no
means united on what the implicit
association test means by no means.
And it has plenty of severe critics and
even the people who have produced it
admit that it shouldn't be used for
diagnostic purposes.
Wink,
wink,
wink.
So,
and then there is no evidence whatsoever
that unconscious bias retraining,
especially if it's mandatory eat first
of all,
reduces unconscious bias,
which you can't measure very well
anyways or has any positive effect on
explicit behavior.
And so I thought the,
the attempt by the HR department to make
that mandatory,
it was an unwarranted intrusion on the
civil rights of the employees using
pseudoscience as a mask.
And so I was thinking about these things
at like two in the morning and I
thought,
well,
I can't sleep and I learned when I can't
sleep to go right.
And this time I thought,
no,
I'm not going to write this down.
I'm going to make youtube videos
instead.
We'll see what happens.
Yeah.
So I sat in front of my computer and I
made these like low quality videos and
the content was pretty good.
I laid out why I was irritated about
bill,
see 16 and talked about the background,
you know,
context of the legislation.
And then I made another one come telling
the HR department at the university that
what they were doing was completely
unwarranted and that they had no
business doing it whatsoever and that
they should stop.
And so then I released the videos and I
thought then I went to sleep.
And you know,
the reason I made the videos was because
I wanted to think these things through,
right?
So,
so like I'm doing onstage right now,
I'm thinking things through,
it's like something was bothering me.
And so I was trying to lay out the
arguments and trying to figure out why
it bothered me into put a logical,
you know,
to,
to arrange it in a logical manner and to
try to communicate it.
And you do that partly because you
think,
well,
this is bugging me and here's what I
think it is,
is like,
is it bugging you too?
And how about you?
And,
and if it isn't bugging any of you,
well then I'm probably crazy.
But if it's bugging all of you to,
and then,
you know,
maybe there's something here.
And so that's why you have to be able to
speak freely,
right?
Because you have to be able to bumble
around with your thought and formulate
things and then see how other people
respond to it and they'll criticize you
or maybe agree with you and you get to
modify what you're thinking.
And so,
and plus I was experimenting like I
often do.
I was experimenting with Youtube.
It's like,
well,
let's see what happens.
Well,
that was quite something
so,
well,
the first thing that happened was there
was a big demonstration,
like an anti Peterson demonstration.
So I've had my own demonstration and
that was in front of the building I
worked out.
And not too many people came,
but they were people.
The people who came were calling me the
sorts of names that Eric was called,
or the Brett was called,
you know,
he's a bigot and a transphobic and
racist.
Oh,
I was a racist because the HR department
at the university had taken advice from
black lives matter in formulating these
policies and black lives matter in new
Toronto was led or established by two
women who I thought were reprehensible
and had nothing to do with their race.
Like,
I don't care who you are,
you can be reprehensible.
And they were reprehensible in my
estimation.
And there was plenty of documented
evidence for that.
And so I said,
well,
why the hell are we taking advice on our
hr policies from,
from these people?
It's like,
when did that become acceptable?
And so that,
that's why I was a racist.
So,
and,
and so,
you know,
all of these accusations were thrown at
me and I thought about that a lot in the
last year.
It's like,
what was that reasonable?
And it's actually kind of reasonable in
a weird way because Canada's a stable
country and has been for a long time.
It's pretty peaceful and things work
pretty well.
And so if you pop your head up and say
something stupid and reprehensible is
going on,
the Canadians say,
no,
this is Canada.
You're crazy.
And which is the right response.
Right.
And so then they throw a bunch of things
at you that might match the kind of
crazy you are.
And if one of them sticks then well then
they can ignore you.
And you know,
I'm,
I'm obviously being a bit facetious and
it's not like the people who are doing
this to me didn't know exactly why they
were doing it and it isn't like they
were trying to bring me down and destroy
me because they certainly were.
And then 200 faculty members and
graduate students and the like from the
disciplines that you'd expect wrote a
petition saying that I had made the
university an unsafe place.
And uh,
and then there was a counter
demonstration that the students who
decided to support free speech set up
and they asked me to speak and lauren
southern to speak and um,
a couple of other people and they had an
open mic session so that anyone could
speak and it was out in front of the
same building.
And there was quite a few people at
that.
There was about 200 people.
And,
and I went out there and that there was
some bad guys there,
you know,
there were just your typical students
who were confused and squawking away and
chanting,
but peppered among them were the types
of people who were seriously looking for
trouble.
And I can,
I'm a clinical psychologist,
I've worked with all sorts of people.
I can identify people like that.
They're not very common,
thank God.
But there were plenty of them at that
rally and they,
it could be any kind of rally where the
possibility for trouble was emerging and
they would have been the type that was
going to be there.
So I was keeping my eye on them and they
were blasting white noise and there were
unplugging our PA systems and,
and stealing the mic and,
and you know,
just behaving in a manner that should
have been shut down by the university
authorities but wasn't,
but the university authorities were
taken off guard by all of this and they
didn't really know what to do and they
weren't really aware of the underlying
legal transformations that were going on
in our society.
And anyways,
they unplugged the mic.
And so then I talked very loudly about
the necessity for free speech and that
was recorded and went online.
And then I left and I came back about
two hours later to talk to the cops and
uh,
to see if anything I didn't,
I was hoping that nothing of any
significance,
no one was hurt.
So I wanted to go talk to the cops and
see if it all went okay and I went and
talked to them.
And then when I came back,
this group of trans activists protestors
who claim to be speaking for the Trans
Community,
which doesn't exist,
there is no trans community.
They're not a homogenous group.
They don't all think the same way.
And besides,
you don't become the spokesman for a
person by claiming that you're the
spokesman just because you happen to
share some of the attributes of that
group.
But we're so guilty about the treatment
of minorities that were willing to
regard anyone who plays that particular
card as worthy of listening to.
And that's a big mistake because you
know,
there,
there's valid representation and invalid
representation.
Anyways,
they surrounded me and videotape the
exchange.
And it was one particularly noisy person
there who was quite dismissive and
insulting.
And I tried to have a conversation.
And,
um,
the first thing this person said was
that Peterson,
what do you think about the Nazis that
were at your rally?
And I thought,
you know,
you'd have to really look hard in Canada
to find a Nazi.
They're just,
there just aren't that many of them,
you know,
so,
so I,
I thought it was preposterous to begin
with.
And,
um,
I said,
well,
I don't,
you know,
what do you want me to say?
It's like,
welcome Nazis.
It's no,
it's like I said,
I don't like Nazis,
you know,
and,
and she said,
well,
what about,
you know,
the fact that they were here?
And I said,
well,
I can't control who happens to appear
somewhere.
And it was all,
it was all false.
None of that was true at all.
It wasn't even a little bit true,
but you know,
it's an easy weapon to,
to haul out.
And so they sh she,
he,
no,
I'm not being smart about that.
It was like this was a trans person and
I don't know exactly,
I couldn't figure out how to refer to,
we'll say her and I got health without
too.
And I tried to have a conversation and
it was just,
she was just blaring nonstop ideological
like nonsense at me,
you know?
And just,
it just hurt cause I like to talk to
people,
you know?
But I really do not like having
ideological slogans glared at me.
I didn't really,
I find it,
I don't know exactly how,
what,
how I find it,
but
it's like,
it's like really loud white noise.
It's something like that.
Or maybe it's worse than that.
It's like static.
It's like really loud,
static.
It's jagged.
And I said,
look,
you know,
like quit that.
It's like I can't,
I'd like to talk to you,
but I can't tolerate that.
You know what slogan means?
Slogan is derived from Tube,
Welsh,
word slew ag and Gerome and it means
battle cry of the dead.
So that's really,
we're thinking about man.
The next time you want to like have a
slogan on your tee shirts,
just remember who you're standing for.
It's like you're the skeletal army of
zombies come to life and,
and they are possessing you,
right?
It's their words,
your mouth thing.
It's nothing alive and it's not
something that likes life.
It's a horror show.
That's what a slogan is.
Anyways,
they videotaped all this and they're
going to put it online to show what a
reprehensible creature I was.
So they did.
And that didn't work out.
Things being viewed about three and a
half million times now and the positive
comments out number of the negative
comments like 99 to one,
something like that.
And so that was an interesting case of
that inversion that Jonathan was talking
about.
You know,
how everything's upside down.
And so they tried one tactic and it just
flipped on them completely.
And so,
uh,
but,
but here's,
here's something to think about.
Like if one person who was nominally
supporting me at that rally would have
done anything stupid whatsoever that was
captured on videotape,
I have been sunk.
Right?
And so we're in this situation where the
actions of specific individuals have a
determining effect far beyond what we're
accustomed to.
You saw that in Charlottesville where
that guy ran somebody over with a car
and it was like political polarization
in the u s increased instantly by 10%
right.
And that's part of the,
I said like social media isn't an echo
chamber,
it's an amplifier.
And so,
well,
so I was very fortunate and then this
person also said that she had watched
all my youtube videos and I looked at
her because that was ridiculous because
there was like 200 of them online by
that point.
And like
some people I presume have now watched
all 200 of them,
but it's like 500 hours of content.
So I knew that that was complete rubbish
and basically said as much.
And anyways it went well for me and it
didn't go so well for the protesters and
then the university.
And so that was my first encounter with
Youtube and its tendency to amplify and,
and also what the tight rope line is
when these sorts of things happen,
you know,
and for a whole year it's not quite so
bad now,
although it's just about as bad.
I lived in absolute terror of ever have
two things ever saying the wrong thing,
even if it was clipped out of context,
right.
Or having something unearth that I said
before,
that was the wrong thing,
even if it was taken out of context.
Now luckily,
and this was kind of unique,
I already had 260 videos,
200 videos up.
And so when I was being accused of all
of these things,
I could say,
well you know,
have add or there's 500 every single
word I've said to students in the last
20 years is being recorded.
If you want to find some Nazi
propaganda,
it's like,
have adder man.
Good luck to you.
And of course it was not only false,
it was,
it was antithetical to the truth because
I've been teaching people about Nazi
atrocities for 30 years and trying to
help people understand how it was that
it would be likely had they been in Nazi
Germany,
that they would've been on the side of
the Nazis and not on the side of the
Jews.
You wouldn't have been the hero,
you would have been the perpetrator
statistically speaking,
and that you really need to understand
that.
So I was fortunate,
I was protected by that backlog of
information.
And so that was really good.
And then the university did it.
Another thing that reversed,
you know,
they wrote me a letter saying,
all these people are complaining,
you're making the campus and unsafe
place,
you have to and your might be violating
our code of conduct and the law.
And I thought,
I didn't know what to make of that
letter.
I told them to take the letter back
because I said,
look,
if you're going to go after me,
because I actually liked the University
of Toronto.
So if you're gonna go after me,
you should go after me correctly.
And this,
this document is actually untrue in that
it contains sins of omission because you
may have got letters from the staff
saying what a reprehensible person I
was.
But you also got 15,000 signatures on a
petition and hundreds of letters from
people supporting me.
And you didn't say anything about that
in the letter.
So how about we,
you know,
you write a letter that says,
well some people aren't very happy with
you and other people are,
but we've decided that what you're doing
is too risky and you know,
you should stop,
but they wouldn't take it.
So I read it online and that's what was
interesting too because now if something
happens to you,
it doesn't have to be secret.
I didn't even comment on it except maybe
with raised eyebrows from time to time,
I just read it and say,
you draw your own damn conclusions here.
And so,
and I was actually,
I wouldn't say secretly happy about it
because I wasn't,
because my job was at risk and that
wasn't all that was at risk.
But my job certainly was,
but I had said when I made the video
criticizing bill c 16 that the act of
making the video was probably illegal.
And then the university came out and
said,
what you're doing is probably illegal.
And so my claims,
which the press,
the press was very divided about this.
And they thought,
well maybe I was being too radical in my
claims.
But then the university came out and
said,
well,
you're probably violating the law and
you should shut up.
And I said,
Ha,
I told you that that's how this law was
constructed.
And so,
and then they did it again.
But,
and I know how HR departments works.
It's like one letters like shut the hell
up.
Second letter is we told you once
already to shut up.
Third Letter says,
we told you twice you didn't.
So like now you're in trouble.
And then the fourth letter is see you
later.
And if you're a tenured faculty member
and you break the law,
that's sufficient to be be nodded,
tenured faculty members.
So they were gearing up to do this and
well then,
well to say that,
well man,
that was really something.
Then what happened was there were
reporters at our house for for like four
months lined up just all the time,
literally eight hours a day.
The reporters coming in,
reporters going out,
there's about 250 newspaper articles
published in Canada about this over
about a two and a half month period.
And that didn't count the podcasts and
the radio shows and the TV coverage.
And like it just,
it went absolutely.
It was absolutely insane.
I've never seen anything like it.
And See,
I was trying to figure out what was
going on at that point because my sense
when I made the videos was this had
nothing to do with transgender rights.
This is indicative of a deep war of
ideas and this is just the latest
manifestation of that deep war of ideas.
So maybe it was a war at a philosophical
level or even a war at a theological
level,
which I actually,
I actually think it's such a deep,
or that it is a ward,
a theological level.
Um,
and that was sort of the level at which
I was going after it.
And I believe that subsequent events
demonstrated that that was the case
because what should have happened,
I always think of counterfactuals,
you know,
if a client comes into my office and the
first time I see them and they're all
upset because they couldn't find a place
to park in there late and they're all
apologetic and I think,
okay,
well now I know something about you
because you could have come in here and
said,
why the hell didn't you tell me where
the parking was?
I'm late.
Or,
or you could've said thought to
yourself,
well,
this is my time anyway,
so I don't have to apologize.
So you run these counterfactuals that
helps you understand the world better.
And I thought,
well,
what should have happened was that I
made these videos two in the morning to
15 minutes long.
There's a little flurry of interest and
then it's like onto the next thing.
But that is not what happened.
That didn't happen even a little bit.
What happened was so opposite from that,
that I still don't know what to make of
it.
And of course this is part of it,
the fact that I'm here talking to all of
you people and,
and so,
and then what happened was that the
press flipped and came on my side.
So 200 Canadian newspapers,
there's a consortium came out and said,
well,
we support Peterson.
And then a huge number of mainstream
journalists like the powerful
independent mainstream journalists,
Barbara K,
um,
uh,
Antonella,
what's Nellis last name?
Can you ever remember names?
So embarrassing.
Margaret [inaudible],
Conrad Black,
um,
at crazy new fee.
He goes on CBC at night.
Uh,
what's his name?
Rex Murphy.
Yeah.
They all came out on,
on my side because what they did,
they did the journalistic homework and
they went and read the things I read and
they found out that if anything,
I was understating the catastrophe that
was written into the Ontario Human
Rights Commission website.
So for example,
one of the catastrophes was they wrote
in a social constructionist view of
gender identity that's law in Canada
now.
And like,
it's hard to say exactly how significant
that is.
If you don't know.
What it means is maybe is that to have a
view that biology is the primary
determinant of gender identity is now
illegal.
Now,
I don't know that for sure.
And you can say,
well,
maybe that's alarmist,
but hey,
I know how ideas unfold across time.
You know,
you have an idea,
you put it in the law,
the law is a living thing.
It's got lots of tentacles.
Nobody knows how it unfolds.
You throw something new in there,
you don't even know what it is you're
throwing in.
You throw a demand that a social
constructionist view of gender identity
is now legally true.
It's,
well,
what do you do with all the evolutionary
biologists like,
like Brett who say,
no,
that's wrong.
It's partly socially constructed,
like everything is among human beings.
And so anyways,
the journalist went and wrote,
read that and um,
they thought,
oh,
well this guy,
first of all,
isn't any of those things that he's
being accused of.
One of the funniest days of my life was
I went to this lecture,
um,
where I was being accused of being a
racist and a transphobic and a bigot and
all of these things in the same day,
literally the same day,
there were 30 people in my house on the
third floor and about 15 of the more
from this native tribe Kwakwaka'Wakw,
they live on northern tip of northern
Vancouver.
And I just stablish to relationship with
a carver there named Charles Joseph,
who recently had a huge totem pole
erected in front of the Montreal Museum
of Fine Art.
I established a working relationship
with him.
He was at a residential school survivor
and I'd been buying a bunch of his art
and I built a replica of modern replica
of a Kwakwaka'Wakw big house on my third
floor with his help and filled it with
totem poles and all these things.
And he brought a bunch of his people to
the Toronto and had induction ceremony
and I was inducted into their tribe.
And that was the same day.
It was like,
what do you make of that?
It's,
it's such,
it's so surreal.
You know,
to go from one of those worlds to the
other.
And I had many surreal days like that.
Anyways,
then I had this debate at the
university,
which the university graciously decided
to host.
And I talked a lot to the dean and we
kind of came to some terms and they
basically decided that they would leave
me alone.
And I had a terrible catastrophe of
health in December.
I just,
it was absolutely unbearable.
I don't exactly know what happened,
but I could barely get it.
Get going to teach in January.
Yeah.
It was very shaky for,
for like two months.
But I,
but it,
it went forward and the students were
very welcoming and inviting,
so that was very good.
But then all of this crazy background
media,
uh,
explosion didn't quit at all.
It just kept snowballing and snowballing
and snowballing and,
you know,
and then I was talking to people,
Gad Saad was one of the early people who
interviewed me,
you know,
and I'm going to be speaking with him at
noon on November 11th in Toronto.
And I'm actually quite afraid of that
because I think the radicals who shut us
down at Ryerson,
I know full well,
they're planning to come out in full
number.
And I really don't.
I'm really concerned about that.
And if you know anybody who's going and
who's purportedly supporters,
let's say of what we're doing,
I really would like you to encourage
them to like keep the,
keep themselves in control.
It's like,
I know there might be agent provocateurs
in the crowd because these people are
certainly capable of that.
But I don't want anything stupid to
happen now.
We're not going to cancel it because,
because we're not canceling it and
that's that.
But I don't want anything stupid to
happen.
It would be better if it didn't.
So,
um,
anyways,
I talked to Gad,
Saad and then a whole bunch of other
youtubers and then I got to be aware of
this whole Youtube universe that,
you know,
that,
uh,
Jonathan was talking about.
And that's been an unbelievably bizarre
experience because it is the case that
there's nothing really uniting us in
some sense.
We're very different people.
Like,
I'm very different than,
than Joe Rogan,
for example.
And I was on this show called h three h
three the other day,
and he's this crazy Israeli clown
comedian,
you know,
and,
uh,
Dave Rubin's and married gay guy and you
know,
and while in Gad,
Saad is a Lebanese refugee,
basically it,
there's nothing about us.
It's the same except something is
uniting us and we all kind of know about
each other down.
We're all communicating and,
and I don't know what that means
exactly.
Um,
I don't know what that means.
And then at the same time,
so that's all been extremely strange,
this multiplication of,
of voice that the Internet provides,
you know,
for better or for worse.
And I think that is what it is.
It's a,
it's a moral amplifier.
And I also think that these AI systems
that we're building,
our moral amplifiers and,
and they're,
they're going to be moral amplifiers to
a degree that we can't even imagine even
knowing how much facebook and twitter
and so forth,
our moral amplifiers.
So we bloody well better be careful
because we're building super intelligent
machines and they're going to be
patterned on us.
So,
so we have to watch our step.
And that's basically what I've been
telling people,
you know,
because I've been trying not to be
political about this.
In some sense I think it's a
degeneration because I'm more
philosophically minded and it's it.
When when things become political around
me,
it's like I'm at the wrong level of
analysis.
I'm not facing things properly.
But I've also found that,
and this has been a strange thing to
see,
I've been talking to people about
responsibility and truth and and
religious topics as well now for really
intensely for the last year,
really for my whole career,
but really intensely for the last year.
And one of the things that strange,
and this is another way the world is
upside down,
is that after being fed a nonstop diet
of freedom and rights for 60 years,
people are starving to death for a diet
of constraint and responsibility.
And who the hell would've ever thought
that was salable?
You know what?
I have people coming up to me all the
time.
Lots of it already happened many times
today.
They say,
well,
you know,
you've talked about responsibility.
I've been listening to your youtube
videos.
It's really straighten out in my life.
I now have a purpose.
I'm not nihilistic.
And when I talk to people about
responsibility and rights,
especially young men in my audiences are
mostly young men.
Man,
you can hear a pin drop.
You think,
well,
what's going on there?
That's so weird.
It's like it's this,
it's this crazy inversion.
It's the least salable thing possible
has become the thing that's most in
demand.
Say like,
have a hard life.
Do something difficult.
Get Yourself,
get your act together quick,
blaming other people.
Assume that you're the problem.
Start small with like non heroic
activities.
Don't broadcast it in public,
right?
Pick up something heavy and assume that
you're contributing in some important
manner to the destiny of the world and
like late your soul quake.
When you understand what that means and
everybody's thinking,
yes,
that's exactly what I want to hear.
It's exactly what it's like.
What the hell [inaudible] and then
there's these biblical lectures on,
I thought,
I thought this is another upside down
thing.
I thought,
okay,
as I put business plans together before
and you know,
I know how you evaluate a business plan.
So here's the business plan.
I'm going to lay out $60,000 to rent a
theater for 12 weeks and I'm going to
deliver a series of lectures on the
Bible and that's a profit generating
enterprise.
Do you want to invest?
It's like,
you know,
get this guy needs antipsychotic
medication and he needs it quickly.
And so,
so I thought,
well,
I'm doing this because I want to walk
through these stories.
And the reason I want to walk through
these stories is because they're
foundational stories.
I understand that there,
there are foundational stories for
better or for worse,
and we can't get rid of them without
getting rid of the foundation.
And that's a bad idea.
So at least we better understand them
before we dispense with them,
you know?
And that goes for me too.
And so I started doing that and they're
ridiculously popular.
Like they always sell out.
The audience is dead silent when and,
and the,
the atmosphere of the room is really,
really positive.
Not In that Namby Pamby you know,
wretched,
harmless way,
but in the sort of charged energy
looking for a good thing to do way.
And the questions are really intelligent
and so,
and,
and deep too.
And so that's really cool.
And then,
you know,
I released them on the net and the most
popular video I have ever made is an
introduction to the idea of God,
which is the intro to this biblical
series and it's got like 850,000 views.
And,
and then I get all these,
like Jonathan said,
he's got all these atheists supporting
him.
He's a bloody orthodox icon.
Carvers.
What the hell's up with that?
And like a tremendous number of the
people who are writing me and commenting
on youtube are also atheists.
They're saying,
well,
you know,
I'm an atheist,
committed atheist and,
but I've been really interested in what
you've been saying about these religious
stories.
And so that's another indication of the
fact that everything's upside down.
And so,
and I'm going to keep making those
biblical videos because I've been trying
to sort through my priorities and I
don't know what my priorities are
because my life has completely surreal.
Like I,
it's like I'm in a,
well,
it's like I stepped into a parallel
universe,
you know?
And so I've been trying to figure out,
well what should I be doing?
And one thing I do know is that I had
been going to continue with those
biblical lectures because I think they
might be the most significant thing that
I'm doing.
Um,
okay.
And then I'll just close and say,
well,
you know,
with my colleagues,
I've also been working on these programs
that help people get their lives
together.
Like the self authoring suite for
example,
which some of you might be familiar
with.
And of course,
one of the things that's been a
consequence and we've done research on,
especially the future authoring program,
really helps people,
you know,
if you give it to university students,
especially the ones that don't know what
they're doing and are kind of alienated,
they're way more likely to stay in
university and they get much better
grades.
So that's really cool.
And so the,
the Internet and these new communication
channels has also made it possible to
deliver reasonably high quality
psychological interventions that are
devoted to helping people improve their
lives and straightening themselves out
at extremely low cost,
extraordinarily widely.
And so now thousands and tens of
thousands of people have done those
programs now.
And so I get letters all the time from
people saying,
this has really helped me.
And you know,
I was on the verge of suicide and this
brought me back from the brink.
And like,
it's really nice to get letters like
that,
you know?
And here's something else that's
interesting.
You know,
people have been assuming that I'd been
deluged by hate mail,
you know,
so they're feeling kind of sorry for me.
And like,
I've like had five pieces of hate mail
in the last year and that's it.
So like I don't understand that it's,
I dunno what it is.
Maybe the sjw types don't have the
energy to pen a hate letter,
although they certainly seem to,
but for some reason,
although they'll come out and protest
like they did it.
Mcmaster,
they're,
they're not,
they're not really directly going after
me with,
with those sorts of channels of
communication,
someone spectacularly reprehensible,
just littered my neighborhood.
I actually know who it is littered my
neighborhood with community safety
warnings,
you know,
claiming that I was,
well,
you know,
the General Satan himself in various
manifestations essentially.
And one of the things that was so funny,
if you find these sorts of things funny
is that they have this picture of me
that's the background of the poster.
Like I'm looking really aggressive,
a yelling like,
like really like I'm going to bite a
child.
And so that's the,
that's that's the community safety
warning rights.
Look out for this man and here's,
here's the way they play fast and loose
with the truth.
So that picture was from that free
speech rally I told you about.
And the reason that I'm yelling is
because the same people,
because I know who did it,
the same people,
we're the ones who took the microphone
and the PA system.
And so the only way I could communicate
with the crowd was to yell.
And so I look kind of aggressive and I
was kind of irritated day.
It's like what the hell white noise.
You're blasting me with white noise and
you're taking the amps and no one's
doing anything about it.
It's like I'm not going to stop talking
because you're because of your dopey
tricks.
And so I was,
you know,
reasonably fired up and I had to talk
really loudly cause there was white
noise blaring.
And so that's the picture that they use
to show the demonic side of Jordan
Peterson.
And that's such a lie.
Aa.
That's the lies embedded right in the
poster.
It's like the only thing you could find
that would make me look reprehensible is
an action that I took as a direct
consequence of your misbehavior in a
public forum.
But they don't care.
They don't care or maybe they do care
and maybe they're happy that the base of
the poster is a,
is there an extraordinarily deceptive
false hood?
You know,
they're happy about that.
So.
All right,
so let's sum up,
okay.
You know,
I'm not going to make a case for the
antipathy of the old media to the new
media because I've actually been treated
pretty well by the old media.
And I can tell you that the Canadian
journalists,
the ones that you respect are very much
afraid for their personal safety,
for the reputation and for their
livelihood.
And so they're actually quite brave.
Margaret went is a good example of that,
but so are the other people that I
listed.
Christie Blatchford is another one and
it's,
and it's an anti Nela
still didn't get it
anyways.
So it's not like they're high and mighty
people who have a tremendous amount of
power who are like misusing their status
there.
They're not there.
They're walking on eggshells.
All those media empires are crumbling,
crumbling,
like mad the globe and Mail is
crumbling.
CBC is crumbling.
They can't get anybody to watch any of
their stuff online because they don't
understand the,
the,
uh,
um,
the ethos.
But like,
I don't see it as a polarization exactly
between the old media and the new media.
I just see it as we're in the brave new
world of instantaneous,
permanent verbal communication.
And no one has any idea what that means.
And so it's producing all these strange
phenomena like these new youtube stars
that have really come out of nowhere
and,
and people are attracted to them because
of the raw [inaudible] and their,
and their unedited quality.
You know,
when Joe Rogan posts,
hosts posts a video,
it's every bit of it's posted.
So you get to make up your own mind
about what you're going to conclude.
And so that seems to be a really good
thing.
So maybe that means that free speech is
alive and well,
you know,
and maybe it's even flourishing.
Who knows?
So I can't draw any real conclusions
about where we're at with regards to
media except the one I started with,
which,
which is,
and it's sort of related to this message
of personal responsibility,
which is a,
your voice is amplified far beyond what
it ever has been in the past.
If for every single one of us and it can
get amplified if you're not careful,
it can get amplified way more than you'd
ever hope or suspect.
Like,
you know,
if you make the wrong mistake in your
life,
at some point you could be the next
viral video.
You know?
And that's pretty terrifying thought and
it's no wonder people are anxious about
all of that.
But I do think it amplifies your effect
on the world.
And so it's all the more reason to get
your act together and to be careful with
what you say and be careful with what
you do.
Because now we're at a point in history
where the fact that you're intimately
connected with the rest of mankind,
let's say present and future is manifest
almost instantaneously.
And we need to take that seriously and
hopefully we can take it seriously
enough so that we ramp the polarization
back,
you know,
and figure out how to communicate with
one another and put things straight
again at a deep level so that we can
move towards a positive future.
Cause we could have one,
you know,
like things are shaky and chaotic right
now in strange and surreal on multiple
dimensions.
But we're also on the cusp of a
technological revolution,
the likes of which no one can even
conceive.
And maybe things could become incredibly
much better if we're,
if we walk carefully and think carefully
and orient ourselves properly.
And,
and,
and so that's what I hope that we all
do.
And that's what I'm trying to promote
when I do my videos and all of that.
So,
um,
and that seems to,
people seem to find that useful and they
actually seem to be doing it.
And I think that's better than engaging
in the polarized wars and trying to be
right and when the arguments and all of
that,
because I just don't think that that's
going to work.
So,
so be careful and be awake and pay
attention to what you say and clean up
your rooms.
And that's good enough.
Thank you.
[inaudible].
All right.
Yes.
So our next thing will be the q and a
paddle.
We will get that going as soon as
possible.
Uh,
but for the moment,
we are millennials and we do want some
group pictures,
so bear with us.
Yeah.